new information Has Come Out on Just how
insanely corrupt Ukraine is this morning
Ukraine's government is in the midst of
a purge that is because of this scandal
in the defense Ministry so what we're
seeing here is the Ukrainian government
cleaning house we're sending them
billions of dollars and corrupt
Ukrainian officials are blowing it on
lavish vacations private jets luxury
cars Yachts clothes ever since Russia
invaded Ukraine in February 2022 America
has sent nearly a hundred billion
dollars in Aid to Ukraine that's more
than America gave Afghanistan's military
over the span of 20 years and more than
three times the ages sent to South
Vietnam between 1959 and 1975 but not
all of that money has made it to the
people who actually need it thanks to
Ukraine being one of the most corrupt
countries in Europe that money has ended
up in the hands of Ukrainian oligarchs
ah yes not only does Russia have
oligarchs but so does Ukraine and
they've been spending America's billions
on a lot of other things aside from
defense and the economy and yet no one
is allowed to talk about this several
senior officials including the deputy
defense minister have have resigned
president zielinski elected on a pledge
to crack down on corruption removed a
number of key government figures accused
of misusing their positions for their
own gain see before the war in Ukraine
started the news had a lot to say about
just how corrupt and backwards Ukraine
really was these days the corruption in
Ukraine is all over the news he was the
president of Georgia then a governor in
Ukraine and now he's in jail are
allegations of corruption that stretch
all the way back to Panama but once
Russia invaded all of that disappeared
now don't get me wrong The Invasion is
clearly wrong Russia is clearly a fault
here but doesn't one tenth of a trillion
dollars in Aid call for at least a
little bit of accountability since it is
money coming up your pocket into the
hands of the American government in the
form of taxes and then after Ukraine
stay dangerous and this is the insane
corruption happening right now in
Ukraine
accused of misusing their positions
and really fast if you've been wanting
some truly wireless earbuds but you
don't want to Shell out the money for
airpods or other overpriced options then
you gotta check out that everyday
earbuds by raycon when I first got these
and I was pretty skeptical I thought at
such an affordable price there was just
no way this thing could compete but I
was proven wrong these raycons are an
insane value and they've become my go-to
earbuds when I exercise you get a super
secure fit they're really low profile
much lower profile than my expensive
Sony earbuds that way I can run and lift
in them without having to worry about
them snagging onto something then
falling on the ground and then having to
sanitize them but the best part is that
you get premium audio at a fraction of
the cost of other big name brands you
can pick from five different colors it
comes with a one year warranty and
there's a 30 day happiness guarantee too
so if you're ready to buy something
small with a big impact click the link
in the description box below or go to
byracon.com jaketran to get 15 off your
raycon purchase that's by raycon.com
with the link below to get 15 off your
purchase thanks to raycon for answering
this video
[Music]
Ukraine became independent from the
Soviet Union in 1991 but here's the
thing about living under a Soviet
dictator for almost 70 years people
started forgetting what it takes to run
a country on their own and that's
exactly what happened to Ukraine when it
officially split from the Soviet Union
it was left with a massive power vacuum
it needed a president a constitution
loss caused a working government and
that stuff doesn't just appear out of
thin air overnights so who stepped out
to the plate to guide Ukraine to its new
independent future the same powerful
families and businesses that thrive
during Ukraine's Soviet years and
suddenly corruption became a core part
of how the new country was run Ukraine
became the wild west of Eastern Europe
things like bribery putting family
members in positions of power backdoor
deals these things worth the exception
they weren't crimes they weren't forced
upon the Ukrainian governments they were
fundamental to how the government
functioned it's crazy to think about
this if you live in the west but this is
how most small countries operate in
America if a government official was
caught bribing his way into his position
everyone is all up in arms but in
Ukraine bribes and favors from powerful
friends was the only way to get into
office nothing could get done without
greasing the right palms and scratching
the right backs but here's the thing
about corruption as much as it was part
of everyday life in Ukraine it was
tapping the country dry off all its
resources like when Russia first invaded
Ukraine in 2014 and none of the
country's Security Forces had the money
equipment or training it needed to stop
it and it was all thanks to Decades of
Ukrainian oligarch siphoning money away
from its intended uses by 2014 Ukraine
and the rest of the world realized it
had a massive problem on his hands how
could Ukraine ever dream of becoming
part of NATO or the EU if it couldn't
even control its own governments and as
much as Ukraine's leadership made a big
show of rooting out corruption things
just went from bad to worse
[Music]
for more than 30 years Ukraine did very
little to stop the corruption in the
governments the only real step it took
towards rooting out corrupt businesses
was a public procurement system called
prozoro and sure prozaro probably did
help make running a business fairer and
easier but it didn't really do anything
about government corruption so
government corruption just got worse and
worse one man in charge of regional
transportation in Ukraine took bribes in
exchange for allocating mini bus routes
to certain companies and drivers he
drove a sports car even though his
salary was only around 170 a month when
people found out what he was doing he
was fired but then he quickly got
another job doing the exact same thing
in a different district and that was
just one example on the lower end of the
Ukrainian government's food chain just
this year it was revealed that the
ministry of defense's head of
procurement had paid 2.7 million dollars
for 3 000 bulletproof vests turns up the
vests weren't very bulletproof and were
quote unable to properly protect
Ukrainian Soldier address but that
didn't matter the official got the money
from the real bulletproof vests bought
cheaper ones and had already pocketed
the difference and that's not even the
worst of it one government official took
an almost four hundred thousand dollar
bribe to buy overpriced generators While
most of Ukraine doesn't have access to a
stable power supply while the ministry
of Defense signed off on contracts two
supplies shoes for food that cost two to
three times the regular price and these
are just a few examples that we know of
and how are these Ukrainian cronies
enjoying all this American money they're
getting they used cars meant for
humanitarian purposes to go on business
trips they use Aid money to take luxury
vacations overseas to buy properties
sports cars they bought hundreds of
thousands of dollars worth of jewelry
designer clothes and luxury gold watches
but no matter how much Ukrainian
corruption was being exposed the
government refused to do anything about
it in 2016 Ukraine's ex-president even
accused anyone reporting on Ukrainian
corruption as signing with Russia it's
Russian propaganda hello which is a
tactic that America has gladly taken a
page out of
oh
President Biden has called the war quote
a battle between democracy and autocracy
between Liberty and repression between a
rules-based order and one governed by
Brute Force End quotes when in reality
America has a ton of other ulterior
motives for supporting Ukraine it's the
perfect excuse to overthrow Putin it's
the perfect time to get Europe away from
Russian natural gas and have them switch
over to American Natural Gas like what
former U.S Secretary of State
Condoleezza Rice has admitted to now for
the long run you simply want to change
the structure of energy dependence
it's also a great way to test America's
ability to mobilize military equipment
for war it's very profitable for the
military industrial complex
reconstructing Ukraine would be very
profitable for firms like BlackRock it
will open up Ukraine even more to
American corporations once it's over
there are a ton of different reasons
that we have covered on this channel
which you can check out with this
playlist by clicking the card on the top
right corner and it's because of all
these reasons that America needs to do
whatever it takes to maintain Ukraine's
appearance as a faultless victim that we
need to keep sending money to it's why
this is probably the first time you're
hearing about a lot of the stuff it's
why anyone who trusts a report on
corruption in Ukraine or the misuse of
American Aid is anti-democratic or
citing where Russia hey when we got into
this what you sold as American people is
you're going to provide defensive
weapons only so Ukraine could defend
itself now we're sending tanks now we're
sending it just came out longer range
missiles these were things that were
totally off the table and then suddenly
step by step by step not only are they
on the table but you're not allowed to
question it you're not allowed to say
hey guys are we setting ourselves up for
World War III here which is something
the president himself was talking about
not very long ago and yet no because we
are talking about a nuclear armed
superpower that we are engaged in a
proxy war with and you're basically not
allowed to say hey how does this end but
now the truth is starting to come out
Ukrainian anti-corruption activists have
been digging up dirt the government have
been trying to hide these activists are
risking everything to publish reports on
corruption even though they know
criticizing the Ukrainian government
during wartime could get them in real
trouble and so far their efforts have
been paying off in the past few months
some of Ukraine's most important
officials have either resigned or
zeliski has had to fire them over
corruption charges
the end goal of America is clear America
wants to open up Ukraine for business so
that American corporations can come in
and siphon the Country Dry just like
what America has done with other
countries time and time again and one of
the last countries they did this to was
Iraq in fact here's Hillary Clinton
admitting that Iraq was a literal
business opportunity and so it's time
for the United States to start thinking
of Iraq as a business opportunity they
don't even try to hide these things I
was going to cover the story in a normal
video but then I remember that anything
about Iraq or the wars in the Middle
East get instantly demonetized so we're
going to be releasing this video in the
next few weeks as a private documentary
available to only members of this
Channel all you have to do to be the
first to watch is by clicking that join
button below remember these private
documentaries are never going to be
released anywhere else it's all the
videos I wish I could make on climate
change CIA torture programs profiting
off of Iraq that just wouldn't fly on
YouTube so while you're waiting for this
Iraq one to be released you can enjoy
all the other ones we've released
already so scroll down click that join
button and learn the truth now